Can you please share, be an email, a copy of your black sad protocol and suggest a good source where this might be purchased?
No, not unless we have a conversation because it's not as simple as that.
You have to be prepped mentally to start black sad and you have to be prepped from a local perspective to have a doctor that could prescribe paid medication if you so need.
We've had people do black sad with out paid medication and not need paid medication, but a lot of people will need paid medication.
In the last phases of the, the, the tumor expelled itself after using back sad could be extremely painful.
Not because the cancer died. There's no pain in killing the cancer cells with the black sad. The pain comes in in the cancer expelled itself. Okay, so I'll give you an example.
You could have a cancer that's the size of a, that's rolled a melanoma that's wrong. Let's say it's a size of a centimeter on your, but it's actually underneath it's the size of a hard boiled egg.
And when you start drawing it out, the skin has to stretch and it can hurt like blazes and you might be able to tolerate it with some artica and, and mind over a batter during the day, but you might not be able to sleep at night for the last three days where it's coming up.
So you might need some paid medications, you need to be prex. So we don't, I don't put the blacks have protocol on the members side for that reason because they don't have people using it that calling it haven't been in a crisis situation.
So we need to have a discussion before you do that.